foreign
for coming along
so as we all know artificial
intelligence is much in the news and
it's hard to avoid some talk about it
either some wonderful new application or
even more likely some possible threat to
human existence that artificial
intelligence might pose
so all of that from the magic of text
generation to music artificial
intelligence like Ava which you can use
to generate massive amounts of Music
copyright free to put on your Tick Tock
video all the way through to the sorts
of algorithms that Google and meta use
to mine their data
I won't be talking about that
those algorithms that write algorithms
and somebody has to program the machine
and then you give it massive amounts of
data
and every time it makes a mistake you
correct it that's the simplest kind
so the initial algorithm will write the
algorithm that learns the function they
are trying to simulate
what we're interested in in particular
my colleagues at the uh Australian
Center for engineered Quantum systems is
building learning machines so machine
learning algorithms that write
algorithms I'll come back to this a few
times we're interested in machines that
learn
now we're all very familiar with
machines that learn
we are machines that learn in fact all
mammals are machines that learn needs to
say we're not simply machines that learn
there's a bit more to it than that but
if you go right back down through the
animal kingdom
you can keep going down as far as you
like but let's go back this far to this
learning machine
which is a nematode worm
whose genome was sequenced 25 years ago
virtually everything that's possible to
know about an animal is known about this
animal
it's one millimeter long
it's comprised of 900 cells
300 of which are neurons that's its
brain so one third of this animal
is made up of neurons which are the
basic constituents of all mammalian
brains or all mammalian learning
machines
it was originally thought that was
simply something like a thermostat if it
got too hot it moved away if it got too
cold and found somewhere warm to sit if
got too much salt it would just move
away
but over the last 30 years or so it's
become increasingly clear that this is a
very sophisticated learning machine
it can respond to Mechanical stimulation
it can become habituated to Mechanical
stimulation it can learn through
associative learning and it can remember
very specific aspects of environment
particularly where to find food and
where to avoid threats
the most interesting thing about it is
the neurons that make it up have been
studied all the way through from genetic
coding of proteins all the way through
to how they actually turn on and off
and remarkably these mechanisms these
molecular mechanisms it's a little
little sort of machine of
learning switches
those molecular mechanisms are conserved
pretty much right through the animal
kingdom all the way up to us
so if we can understand this learning
machine
then we'll have some hope of
understanding what happens in incredibly
complex learning machines such as
ourselves with billions upon billions of
neurons
as long as pointed out
all the mechanisms of learning and that
are conserved and very similar to what
we've got in our own heads
so there are learning machines out there
we have a pretty good understanding of
how they work and so the objective in
our program is to build artificial
learning machines
however you can already buy them to some
extent the kind that you can train with
data the kind that Google and Microsoft
use but you can buy one if you want
they're a snippet 300 000 pounds not to
worry you can get some Finance should
should you need it
you can get much cheaper ones I hasten
to add and of course they run up to
hundreds of millions of dollars if you
really are serious about it
now one of the aspects of contemporary
machine learning of this algorithmic
type of algorithms that write algorithms
is it is unbelievably inefficient in its
use of energy
so here's some numbers
if we look at say air travel for one
person New York to San Francisco that
will produce about two thousand pounds
of CO2
let's look at something a bit more
significant here
a car
average usage including including fuel
over one lifetime
uh 126 000 pounds but let's go down to
one of these natural language processing
machines the really big ones like the
transformer which are used by Microsoft
and Google and others you can see what
the difference is 620 000 pounds of CO2
for one training run
and then of course once it's trained
people want to use it to identify
patterns in data and that will cost a
lot of energy to run and thus produce a
lot of CO2 so it isn't surprising that
Deep Pockets like Microsoft and meta
pretty much and Amazon of course earned
as well because the power bills not to
mention the cost of actually building
the machines and hiring the staff to
program them are enormous
now
it's pretty clear that c elegans isn't
producing that much CO2 and yet it's
still learning quite a lot about it as
well so there is no fundamental reason
why that should be the case
it's just because of the way we've
settled on doing machine learning
through algorithms that write algorithms
and one of the key points I'd like to
present to you today is that by changing
that perspective and building machines
that just learn they won't necessarily
be digital machines there's nothing
about C elegans that's digital with
little switches
building machines that learn will enable
us to have vastly more efficient
learning capability than we have at the
moment through running algorithms on
silicon-based devices
so let me just recap where we've got to
in deep learning
such as used by Amazon web services
saying these are literally machines just
computers silicon-based devices
typically graphical processing units but
perhaps other more optimized devices
where algorithms write the algorithms so
the programmer will set up a basic
algorithm to simulate what was thought
to be the essential idea of a neuron
then by giving it huge amounts of data
and I'll come to an example in a minute
the machine will reconfigure itself and
discover an algorithm for capturing the
pattern in that data so that's the way
deep Learning Works the algorithms that
write algorithms
but what I'm talking about here are
machines where thermodynamics write the
algorithms there is no programmer
the machine is embodied and lives in the
world
sure you can send it signals carrying
data but as we'll come to later it could
be entirely robotic and move around the
world and Learn by itself
and the key point is that it's
thermodynamics that writes the
algorithms and these will run on custom
built systems what do I mean by
thermodynamics why it's the algorithm
it's really very simple in order for a
learning machine to function well in the
world it has to make the most efficient
use of available resources typically
energy
if not
the environment may change and it will
go extinct so it's pretty clear why C
elegans is optimized to be as low power
as possible so we would like to build
machines that function like that
so deep learning is machine learning I'm
talking about learning machines physical
devices
so let me just run through an example
contrasting a machine that learns to an
algorithm that learns
so one kind of machine learning is
called supervised learning where you
give lots and lots of examples of uh
data to a machine with a label here I've
imagined we have silhouettes of sheep
and goats
and in algorithmic machine learning you
would send in all the little pixels
black and white pixels of sheep and
goats
and the way it would work is you would
first train it on all the pixels that
have goats and all the pixels that
correspond to sheep and every time the
machine makes a mistake you adjust it
until finally it makes a very limited
error
in this kind of machine what we imagine
is we literally have a physical device
sitting here
and we put in pictures of sheep and
goats and initially we just choose them
completely at random but they've got a
little label on it so we'll always know
if it comes out with the right label at
the end so initially
they come out random it has no way of
knowing which is a sheep and which is a
goat but every time we make a mistake we
sit here at the output looking for an
error
so here a goaters come out with a sheep
label
we run back and change some
inside the machine this time a physical
actual setting it could be
a chemical gradient it could be an
electrical pulse it could be an optical
signal
any kind
and gradually the machine will start to
recognize what is a sheep and what is a
goat and eventually with small
probability of error almost all the goat
Silhouettes will come out in one channel
and all the Sheep will come out in the
other
now if you think about what's happened
here initially we had this random
assortment of data
but at the end we haven't A random
assortment of data at all apart from the
few mistakes basically the Sheep go to
one side and the goats go to the other
and this means the machine has
dramatically reduced the uncertainty in
this data
the technical word is it's reduced its
entropy
and
if you have a device that reduces
entropy you pay a price
it will have to increase entropy
somewhere out in the world
and in a physical machine that means it
will dissipate heat and energy into the
external world
so the essential lesson that we have
from these sorts of examples is that a
physical learning machine is necessarily
dissipative and produces Heat
it's necessarily irreversible
so learning machines only possible if
the world is intrinsically irreversible
which I think most of us would agree it
is at least in our personal interactions
with it
key Point secondly in understanding in
physics and thermodynamics we know that
if a device is reversible and produces
heat it will necessarily be accompanied
by errors and mistakes and fluctuations
and you might think well that's not good
why build a machine that makes mistakes
well the key lesson is if it doesn't
make mistakes it can't learn
everybody knows this it's called trial
and error if you don't make a mistake
you don't learn anything because it's on
the mistakes that you start to feedback
and change your behavior and it's the
same with these machines
they're irreversible they produce heat
and they necessarily make mistakes in
order to learn now obviously that
wouldn't make too many mistakes and you
don't want them to make no mistakes
because if they make too many mistakes
it'll just keep producing random outputs
of sheep and goats if you can keep the
error and the noise level as low as
possible it takes so long to learn
because you're looking for those special
cases where it makes a mistake to change
the configuration of the machine
so there'll always be an optimal level
of irreversibility and Noise
to optimize the learning rate
now in nature of course the learning
rate is probably optimized by Evolution
if C elegans spent three days what
actually only lives three days so I
couldn't spend three days but if it had
to spend more than three days finding
food they would not still be around so
somewhere at the back of biological
learning machines is the evolutionary
algorithm
nonetheless we want to produce machines
that are optimized to learn
and optimize to produce the smallest
amount of waste energy that we can
manage
that's the key
now let's imagine we take that kind of
machine and we embed it in the world
such as us or C elegans but now we're
actually going to build a device out of
photons or Mechanical Devices or
Electronics doesn't really matter I'll
give an example in a minute of a Quantum
device
so the way it works is here's our
learning machine
which I'll say a little bit more about
in a minute but it has a sensor which
interacts with the world
it physically changes its state when
something from the world comes in the
world does work on it it's necessarily
dissipative because it's got to be a
little switch it's got to switch and say
aha I detected the photon
it also has actuators which act
irreversibly on the world
so these devices are also necessarily
irreversible and produce heat but we
like to keep the heat cost as low as
possible
now how does the machine learn well all
it has access to are its sensor records
and it's actuator records all it knows
is what actions it has taken and what
Sensations it has acquired
so all it knows of the world are
correlations inherent between Sensations
and actions and the purpose of the
learning machine is to find a simple
pattern in those correlations
let me also add it's a bit more than
correlations because learning machines
like this are intervening on the world
they're going out and poking the world
in a particular way and waiting for it
to respond
but you see there's a curious puzzle
here which philosophers are worried
about for pretty much forever and that
is the machine learns correlations
between accentuator it's a sensor and
actuator records
to what extent does that mean it's
learned something about the world
I'll come back to that a little bit
later
so here's a slightly more detailed
picture of how the kind of learning
machines we're building work and in fact
how we work and how C elegans work
one tends to think when you're
interacting with the world that your
brain is something like a video recorder
it's sitting there having all this data
coming in there's a vision recorder
there's a sound recorder there's
something recording vibrations and so on
as I'll explain a minute that's not
really how it works at all
you'll see what happens and you take
this design for a learning agent so it
pokes the world and the world pokes back
it then it simultaneously sends a copy
of what it did to the world to its
learning machine
and the learning machine now makes a
prediction
of what its sensation should be
it then checks its prediction against
what's coming in from the world
and if they're right it does nothing if
they're wrong it goes back and changes
some setting in the machine just like
the sheep and goats
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas